Is your suitcase about to explode because you overpacked?
Use these tips to help you pack without overpacking.
You will need: a suitcase, organization, a checklist, hotel information,...
...travel-sized containers, leakproof bags, and a small carry-on bag or purse.
Step one: Make a checklist of all the items you will need according to your itinerary.
Pack two to three days before your trip...
...to ensure that you don't forget important items.
Step two: Find out which hotel amenities will be included in your room.
Many hotels supply hair dryers, toiletries, and pool towels.
Step three: Pack cosmetics and toiletries in travel-sized containers.
Seal them in a leakproof bag, separated from clothes.
Step four: Keep clothes and accessories to one to two color schemes,...
...allowing you to mix and match separates.
Step five: Bring a couple of quick-dry items that can be handwashed.
Step six: Distribute your clothes evenly throughout the bag by rolling your clothes.
Save room in the bag by wearing your bulkiest shoes while traveling to the destination.
Step seven: Keep all your jewelry and other valuables...
...in a small carry-on bag or purse.
Happy traveling!
Did you know?
In 2008, there were 32.8 million bags worldwide...
...that were mishandled by the airlines.